[Music]
we're really excited about getting this
game into players hands Atlanta
experience this massive World a main
Cornerstone of D4 is play your way as a
player continues to advance through the
story and into the end game they'll
unlock a ton of brand new activities
that provide meaningful progression no
matter their play style
players will be able to keep progressing
in The Narrative of the game alongside
that the whole team has worked on
Crafting a variety of different
experiences players can pursue we're
going to have an entire world of
sanctuary for our players to offer
there's going to never be an absence of
something to do after player has
finished the campaign there's a lot more
game to go and participate in they gain
access to a special what we call
Capstone dungeon that they have to
complete once they're able to finish
this Capstone dungeon they're going to
gain access to the first world tier as
you complete the world tier it will open
up the opportunity for you to go into
your next World tier that involves
unlocking powerful loot new items and
more advantages for your player to have
a better opportunity and game whether
you're a fan of dungeons PVP or just
roaming around the world as a way to
continue your Diablo Adventure long
after hitting max level
as your character continues to grow in
power you'll start with the skill tree
and expand out into the Paragon system a
lot of the choice the players make are
grounded on skills themselves and the
fantasies associated with those skills
the Paragon Wars place where we allowed
to have a lot more depth a lot more
customization many more options as you
go you can rotate the board so you can
choose a different path if you're like I
want to do more strength based things so
I want these particular Boons or glyphs
you can chart your path through it and
they're really a way for you to keep
expanding your character and making you
Uniquely Yours
similar to the Paragon boards is the
Codex of power it's an in-game system
that holds the aspects related to the
character you are able to complete a
dungeon and they will have a chance to
drop an aspect that you can pick up what
this allows players to do is take items
they're finding in the world and make
them more powerful turn them into
legendary items it's really special to
discover what kind of playstyle really
means the most to you
every part of sanctuary is fulfilling
and satisfying dungeons in particular
are really loose to my heart nightmare
dungeons are going to give the players
the opportunity to experience a dungeon
that they might have already experienced
in their past playthroughs they'll enter
the dungeon with a found sigil that
alters the playstyle and the intensity
of the dungeon the more difficult and
they have additional objectives and then
they also have affixes which add a
degree of difficulty for you and your
brute to work through
one of my favorite affixes that you can
find nightmare dungeon is actually
called Hellgate occasionally these
portals will open up throughout the area
it will just pour out different monsters
that aren't native to that region for
you to also be dealing with while you're
trying to handle everything else inside
the dungeon
there's over 100 Point dungeons to play
through and find in Diablo 4 and any one
of them can become a nightmare dungeon
by finding a nightmare sigil and then
using it to activate the nightmare
version of that dungeon space
everything's a little darker
everything's more difficult it's going
to add a little bit of a Twist of flavor
on your particular dungeon
there's some targeted activities in
Diablo 4 that suit what you're feeling
in the mood for the force of hell are
starting to have more influence in
certain parts of sanctuary in the vast
interconnected Overworld of the
experience and as the players are going
into hell tight areas you're gonna find
even more powerful monsters and by
killing them they'll be able to gain
these special shards they can take to go
and use to purchase these big rewards
are available at these caches they're
found literally throughout hell-tied
areas the sky darkens and the rivers run
red meteors fall from the sky and the
Monsters get harder we really want to
create new experiences for the players
there's one I really like called
Whispers of the Dead which you get from
the Tree of Whispers The Tree Of
Whispers is grim and a little gruesome
but it's also something mystically
haunting and kind of beautiful the tree
has a little bit of a grudge against our
players and it would like for them to go
serve as needs so you're going to go
serve these bounties gather different
rewards different items and bring them
back to the tree in hopes that it
Exchange you something really meaningful
maybe you're gonna go to the fracture
Peaks and take out some werewolves that
are around painting in a town they're
contained activities that you can do
alone or in a group we really wanted to
create variety for people to be able to
spend time where they wanted to in the
world it's very cool the way it's been
put together and I can't wait for people
to see it to be honest
[Music]
in Diablo 4 we have a focus on the world
of sanctuary and there are parts of that
world that we call the fields of hatred
where Lola's presence and Sanctuary has
begun to seep through and manifest these
poisonous areas throughout the world
when players go to these regions they
get to engage in player versus player
conflict these offer opportunities for
the player to
but fair
shards back
to me to purify them other players will
definitely know that you're attempting
to purify your shirt so you'd better be
prepared to fight if you're going to be
playing any PVP and be prepared that you
might lose some stuff in the meantime
once they've got the purified shards
they can take these go back to nearby
towns to sell them and then use that to
buy a whole bunch of like interesting
cosmetic items and rewards it's a place
for people who really love PVP and want
to still get Loot and still increase
their character's power if that's the
way they want to play they can
[Music]
launch is just the beginning one of the
things we really focused on is creating
a living breathing set of updates for
players to engage with after the game
has gone live it's really just going to
be a way to keep coming back and
experiencing more Diablo 4 in fresh ways
we're really eager to hear all of your
experiences and just enjoy the entire
story with you all
foreign